well let's uh let's let's give a call
here to uh to rex jones
to rex jones i wish you know skype would
since i'm paying for it let me turn off
these sounds
sorry my bad i'll turn on my camera yeah
that'd be good
yeah sorry about that it's okay man
what's up guys
hey there you are how are you doing
how's things oh pretty good not too bad
getting used to uh like trying to create
my own little setup over here so sorry
about the audio quality if it's subpar
or whatever
first off listen we've had people with
way worse audio quality than this
listen it's no better or worse than
milo's and he's been around for four
years he's had eight three years
so yeah we need a nice snowball
we ain't you all [ __ ] flossed out so
how you doing man
so so of course uh rex jones i'm sure
everybody knows him the the son of of
alex
jones wait who's alex jones okay you see
i'm not familiar
i'm not familiar with it well you know
what i call i say i
say alex jones the father of rex jones
because i think
you should get the yeah i think he
should get the name recognition i have
10
i have like 10 000 followers on twitter
i'm not anyone special
jesus hold on first off 10 000 followers
on twitter and you're 16 year old and
doing a show
you're doing a lot better than people
that have been doing shows for a while
so let's
start right there yeah what's your
twitter account so we can oh yeah kicked
off because of who you did so my twitter
account is rex jones news
i also got a youtube under the same name
feel free to follow or subscribe to me
there if you want
um going to be putting out a lot more
content and uh
hopefully trying to make y'all happy uh
putting out like a new informative
viewpoint on some stuff
well that's that's awesome and do you
how long are you thinking like mike was
saying how long thinking to be on
twitter before they uh
kick you off because of your dad they're
doing it with everybody dude
maybe three months i think tops oh okay
thanks i'm trying to get on other
platforms too but like
already like my tweets get flagged for
sensitive content
really if i took anything out at all
yeah like a picture but
but hold on please i'm sorry but it's
funny because i i follow you actually
and
you don't tweet out anything that
wouldn't matter we all
know why i know we all know why he's
getting messed with
you don't tweet on anything that should
be sensitive content
i heavily censored myself on twitter and
i get flagged all the time like i got
flagged for posting that shirtless
picture of my
dad i mean that sensitive content
there's plenty of porn on twitter but
it gets flagged i mean what the hell uh
unfortunately that's the world we live
in so
no i was gonna ask was it one is it was
it the newer shirtless pick or is it
when he's like young and swole
oh no no no no no no no this was like it
was like the first thing i tweeted out i
think was
different and he had like a shirt over
his head like beavis and uh i just
thought it was funny i had in my camera
roll like what's a better way to kick
off your new twitter than posting
something like that
and it got it went it went pretty viral
um it did really well but that was
flagged with sensitive content like
immediately
and it's just him fully clothed except
for like he has a shirt over his head
and apparently that that's uh that's
evil and that's not allowed but antifa
can post videos and like meet ups and
docs people and
that's just chill no yeah it's it's
totally fine you have to forgive us too
because i mean
we're older than you so we might we
might be we we went out all the words
the kids say like eat or whatever
but we're trying to eat people if you
say eat you've been drinking like the
flint michigan water dude
or lean michigan water actually michigan
was made of lean yeah well i didn't know
that yeah no wonder yeah
yeah well there you go half half and
half um
so what what what's what's your show
going to be about what are you going to
talk about
i'm just really trying to start like a
younger youth movement because i feel
like the biggest problem that we have
now like on the right
or just anywhere that's not the radical
left is we have these
massive we have these massive
organizations that are funded by
and i hate to sound like bernie but
funded by billionaires and then they
bring up these people who are like the
chosen ones like ben shapiro and candace
owens and charlie kirk and they
present a very old school um like uh
neocon viewpoint and i just don't like
that at all i'm more of a libertarian
than that you speak in my language
youtube can i tell you right now
i like you it's funny because we heard
the first half we were taught we we
we are so done with the ben shapiro's
and candace owen's actually a leftist if
anybody looks into it she's not
listen here's the thing man i'm huge
pro-america guy i love them i love
america
i have an american flag bumper striker
on my car but here's the deal if you
think that someone should go to jail for
burning our flag you are an
authoritarian idiot
right i mean already ruled on that and
she had a boxing site
uh before she became famous that was uh
supposed to die
what was it called um yeah she tried to
buddy up with zoe quinn
there you go the gamergate and that blew
up in her face and then she was like no
no no i'm right-wing now
as soon as i tweeted something about uh
about the candace owen thing
about the candace own situation when she
said she wanted people to go to jail for
burning the flag
i instantly like that comment section
was like flooded
with these neocon pseudo-intellectuals
17 year olds who are like my age
who found ben shapiro videos roasting
like college liberals
and then oh they think now they think
that they are like part of this elite
group
and it's these like young 18 year olds
that go and they wear suits and they act
like pseudo-intellectuals
it's that whole thing man it's that
whole like it's a whole
elitist vibe i i get that from ben
shapiro and his whole operation is
funded by the koch brothers and it's
funded by that money
same with the young american foundation
same with charlie kirk and kenneth owens
and i can't stand anyone like that
and i'm not saying i'm hell man venture
crew would probably roast me alive in a
debate
but here's the thing i don't have
billions of dollars of funding and i'm
not a harvard i'm not a lawyer i'm not a
i'm not a college graduate yeah he loves
to battle kids
who have like 60 through 80 like iq
points and he goes and he roasts them
and i mean it's not hard it'd be like
like the worst player in the nba i
tweeted this out today like the worst
player in the nba
playing against a fat like morbidly
obese blind kid in a wheelchair that
could
that can only go backwards like that's
what we're dealing with it's
hard to beat these people it's like the
worst player in the nba beating the best
player in the wnba it's still really
simple
it might be the worst but it's still
easy dude but when he goes up against
anyone with any uh like modicum of skill
and hell the leftists were wrong
he loses his cool and he freaks out
because he's used to just
dunking on people and he but he gets he
can't but
but i like that you brought up the the
whole he's fun he's funded by the same
by the same neocon groups the same kind
of people
and and and they they've done this thing
where they
they made bench ben shapiro's a nerd
right
they made they've been trying to make
him cool with all these
thug life videos so it looks like he's
just this
cool young hip guy i see those on my i
see those
um i see those in my youtube feed it's
really weird how youtube suggests stuff
like i've never seen a suggestion for
one of y'all's videos and i follow
all conservative all libertarian
commentator shows i follow a lot of
smaller shows
like um i'm i was super surprised that i
hadn't heard of y'all before and that's
not a dick y'all that's how youtube
album oh no no
trust me we don't take it as a dick
every single [ __ ] time i open my
phone and i don't know what y'all
swearing policy is i'm bad about that
so you can swear go for it every single
[ __ ] time i open my phone
it's ben shapiro thug life ben shapiro
roasted compilation i'm like
what the hell there's obviously an
agenda here if you act like there's not
some big agenda to put ben shapiro on
this pedestal is like the
chosen one for the conservative movement
to lead us off a cliff
there's something wrong with you because
that's clearly what's going on but it is
and i think what bothers me about
shapiro with the most is
he was a never trumper on top of all
that he was he was mystery i'm not
voting for him i'm not going to vote at
the top of the timmy take it i'm just
not going to do it
but now but now he's he's jesus christ
i'm sorry like
i was trying to act [ __ ] cool i did a
backflip i landed it i was super happy
about it so then i decided to go for a
double okay
second rotation i need myself in the
face and i knocked out my two insiders
and my two front teeth now i got it now
i got to say did the chick you were
trying to impress does she at least
notice the double black flip because
that's cool
why that you know what you're homophobic
for assuming it's a girl but it was
like a hassle of course it was a girl
you know what though i got to give you
a real credible humiliating moment in my
life actually that was that was really
sad i gotta be honest with
i didn't even feel the pain i was just
pissed off because i knew that that in
that instant that i had
lost every chance with that with that
person so well if you're look if you're
gonna make it in new media you're gonna
have to learn from the snakey
like the real good snakey ones so you
made a mistake there
you should have immediately started a
gofundme oh yeah antifa knocked my teeth
out there you go
uh they're doxing me and threatening my
family because of who my dad is
and you would have made a punch you
would have made a lot of money see you
should have you should have called
candace owen and charlie kirk you know
how to do that she called like laura
loomer and been like look man what was
the tiger thing remember that help me
out give me some pointers
i could have joined the young americans
foundation and i i could have been
successful but
i ruined my channel i screwed it up
that's the thing i don't even need to
lie
i've been attacked by like antifa and
radical leftists so many times in
airports and public
public spaces every time i go to target
with my dad it's a bloodbath um like
it's ridiculous man really
i ran into bernie sanders at an airport
going on a vacation last year
and um that was very interesting
was it was it with jeffrey epstein i was
on his plane i'm kidding
no thanks jeff we fly commercial in this
family
it was an lax uh last year and he was
bernie looks really bad that i don't
think he'll i don't think he's gonna
live until office back
it was this was back then too like he
was walking he literally had a
pronounced
hump in his back uh he was hunched over
he had like four aides that were all
with them like literally helping him
walk
well that could be a natural posture i
watched the carter video where he said
around to him in the airport and said he
was carrying around two ipad pros i
didn't believe him
he had an ip an ipad pro under each arm
like an old lady carrying groceries he
had an ipad pro and that was like all he
could carry
and of course my dad runs up to him he
starts videotaping that's the whole
thing i'm like oh my god this is a
vacation oh that was when that
that's what we played that video on the
show as a matter of fact
thanks kiddo i gotta go take care of
some business come here you call me son
of a [ __ ] is awesome that was awesome
so anyway getting back to what happened
yeah so the bernie thing was relatively
tame nothing really happened
it was just kind of he ran up to him
with the camera blah blah blah
if you guys walk into the airport i
really don't care i'm not trying i'm not
an nth remember i'm not going to harass
you
my dad does his thing he doesn't he
doesn't touch him he just asks him a
couple questions and when bernie makes
it clear he's not going to answer he
leaves him alone
like a rational journalist would but
then
uh there's this um there's this dude who
was
on our plane ride going to colorado and
he uh when my dad sits back down at the
gate he gets in an argument with him and
the guy was obviously hillary voter he
was like
he was he kind of looked like a weasel
of some kind like he was like
five four five five-ish she had like a
shitty beard
and he had like these huge glasses and
he started arguing with my dad
and they were just yelling at each other
for a good hour uh nothing really bad
happened until the guy
uh turned around and started yelling at
me for no reason i'm just sitting there
i don't give a [ __ ]
on the plane and i hadn't engaged myself
in the conversation with bernie
or in the conversation with this guy and
now this guy just starts hurling insults
my way and
i'm just sitting there and i'm going
like what the hell is going on and the
guy
literally looks at me in the face and
just then just spits at me just this
huge glob of spit
and laying on my face and thank god the
guy didn't have aids because that would
have been bad
um but so because i'm still i'm still
alive so i think i'm safe
um but it takes a while he spits on my
face um
and then uh my dad didn't see it and
then and then he leaves
and then he comes back is where he comes
back after everyone's boarded because he
doesn't want to deal with me and he
doesn't want to deal with my dad and we
get on the plane we fly to colorado
i never think i'm going to see the guy
again surprise surprise
a week later we fly back into austin we
were at the baggage claim
he was there again he was there again on
the same return flight home the guy was
there again
in austin which is bizarre because he we
we ran into him in lax he could have
been from
anywhere but he was from austin and dude
he um this is this is on video he was
there with like his boyfriend or
something
may have been his cousin that kind of
looks it makes sense might be boyfriend
you're right
any anyway hey man i'm not dissing the
guy for that but
it was his boyfriend or his cousin or
his brother or something and
the guy uh the guy starts being really
aggressive and really hostile towards me
and my dad
and then he uh and then he said he says
something to the effect
he starts like throwing out death
threats and that this is when it gets
really serious and we're in an airport
baggage claim you can't
you can't be hurtling around death
threats in the airport dude trust me
trust me i know you can't they really
frown upon that even if they break my
laptop
yeah dude and then the guy spits on me
again
in front of my dad in front of everyone
we have the video footage of this
and him and his boyfriend immediately
leave and
my dad starts to chase them and then
like my uh
my cousin pulls him back because they're
because they're leaving and he doesn't
want to get involved and he says let's
just call the cops
because we got pictures of them and
stuff and obviously they're in the
airport we'll figure out who they are
uh nothing ever came of it the video was
posted on forwards but yeah this is the
kind of stuff i have to deal with
with with these people and they're
complete cowards like they'll do
something like they'll spit on you and
they'll slap you or they'll death threat
you and then we'll just run away
this is the the but it does does it
really even even in austin when you walk
around with your dad you go they really
do bug you guys huh
a hundred percent that's gotta [ __ ]
be tacky yeah meanwhile if he defended
him he would have been [ __ ] it would
have been like all over the place alex
jones attacks
white terrorist alex jones attacks
people in airports
yeah exact patriots and airports because
we'll be eating at a restaurant or
something and then people start coming
up to us
videotaping saying you're a piece of
[ __ ] what do you think about the sandy
hook kids alex what do you think about
that and then i'll be i'll be we'll be
eating food
dealing with these people who are who
see themselves as
like having these like massive having
these massive balls for confronting this
evil right-wing extremist
and meanwhile we're just sitting there
eating chicken like seriously leave
people alone if they're eating in a
restaurant same thing with like the
republicans getting harassed like
seriously leave us alone if we're eating
in a restaurant
the key is the key is to get under their
skin as much as possible if i was eating
dinner and some liberal came up to me
what do you think about the sandy hook
kids i would have went what sandy hook
kids went back to eating my food
and they would have been like they would
have tried
well i just eat my buttery steak you
look angry
it's hard not to feel bad for the people
because they
the people that let me say this we've
never had someone confront us or attack
us and hell i know i'm not the best
looking person i know my dad's not the
best looking person for christ's sake
he's got a massive gut
but these people are all like fours or
below
and right right in that like four to two
range it
it'll either be a land whale some but
someone looks like a meth head
or someone who looks like a keyboard off
like ben shapiro and they will come and
harass us and attack us and you just
gotta feel bad for these people
imagine having nothing better to do yeah
but venture but to be fair i saw a
picture of ben shapiro he has nice tits
now which is pretty cool
you know no he's he's he's got
he's got gyno boobies i think he's on
ssr eyes or something
he's on something right because they're
not they're not the kind of boobs you
get from roids
no no he doesn't strike me as a roid guy
and no it doesn't look natural
dude it wouldn't surprise me if in
shapiro was trying to bulk up
dude do they do they do so so you've
been on twitter for a while have you
gotten a lot of people already uh
[ __ ] on you there too oh it really
depends i went after
some antifa lady because i saw her tweet
something insane
and it was something about like
milkshakes throwing milkshakes
is an assault and i was like uh of
course it is and i got into an argument
with her
and she started virtue said she goes
what have you ever done for people that
are hurt i'm a combat medic
i go and help my fellow like brothers
and sisters when they're injured by the
proud boys
and i'm like uh have you ever seen a
video of an antifa rally it isn't
exactly the proud boys doing the damage
and it's the pro the prop boys are only
doing the
damage for optics but yes i hear what
you're saying no
the only thing they're damaging is sales
of fred perry polos
dude what'd you say sorry my audio cut
out
oh no i was not there it was a joke um
no but anyway yeah i get so ever since
that happened i've had like two or three
like antique patrols in my comments
and again i don't really care one of my
policies says i'm never gonna block
people unless you like threaten me
physical harm
because i'm not i'm not been shapiro i'm
not a [ __ ] i'm not gonna block you if
you say something that pisses me off
um let's talk about it let's have a
discussion i like to be able to reply to
people
that whole thing about just being able
to silence anyone that you don't like
with one click
i think it's really bad and i think it
leads our culture in the wrong path
um now now are you worried though
because i mean
obviously because of who your dad is and
stuff like that are you worried that
you're kind of kind of
be blacklisted to do anything but be in
this kind of
industry you know what i mean not really
man i got it i got good set scores i
assume i'll go to college um i'll be
i'll be able to have a career but man
i'm really interested in doing this and
again um i'm just going by the feedback
apparently people like what i'm doing i
was surprised
i don't like my own voice but um i'm
going to keep doing this
as long as people want to listen and i
really like doing it so
i don't know we'll figure things out as
we go along well again
this is just me and my microsoft surface
and my iphone uh
shooting video and uh putting stuff out
it's my opinion
infowars no connection to this my dad no
connection well i think that's good
that's good for you too though because
you don't want them to de-platform you
for having any connection or being
around
i am not affiliated with him for us in
any way i already have people trying to
get me like kicked off because i was
affiliated with him forwards i've had to
state repeatedly it was in
my first pen tweet over and over and
over again i am not affiliated with
temple wars at all
let me know that that's that's uh that's
good so now what is there anything uh
when's your show when's your show air is
is it a set time every day or are you
just gonna go live
right now we're just doing periscope
lives but eventually i'm gonna i'm gonna
branch out to youtube
soon and eventually we're gonna start
recording a podcast where i have people
on i'm able to talk
in like a longer extended form we've
been doing it for at every day
uh at 5 30 p.m uh central standard time
uh just been doing an hour-long
periscope live stream because i like
being able to discuss
things with people and so i'll have like
a list of topics that i want to talk
about and i'll go
and get questions from the audience and
take their opinions on it eventually i
want to branch out to youtube right now
it's just on periscope so if you're on
twitter
and it's 5 30 central standard time
you've got nothing else to do please
tune into my live i try my best to
answer
each and every question that you'll give
me well uh and what what let's let's
plug your stuff it's been great having
you on
what what's your twitter again rex jones
news
rex news the same name and the youtube's
the same thing
all right man anything else you want to
plug you were great i appreciate you
coming on
oh thanks for having me on no absolutely
again
thank you all for having me on i really
appreciate it you're welcome anytime
you're making sure to check out your
channel more too again the youtube
algorithm is hitting it for me
but uh now now that i know i'll be able
to check you all out i really like what
y'all are
what you ought to say on here all right
man thank you so much for being on dude
appreciate that man
take it easy buddy later bye
all right that was rex jones that's
pretty awesome it's cool you know i just
it does kind of i do kind of feel bad
you mean if you're sick
yeah he's [ __ ] like he's just [ __ ]
like it's just like hey i'm gonna make a
youtube channel no you know no you're
not you're not gonna do anything
it's everybody getting monetized you
know what i mean he would only he would
only have a chance if he had dreadlocks
and he was like my dad was such a dick
that
you're right if he was like such a
[ __ ] dick like
one of the reagan grandson that's a
that's a lefty that guy
dude my dad just would always punch wall
holes in the walls and be like the san
diego kids were
like he's a crazy dude they'd be
throwing him grant money